emphasis on in any moment how you may
see her walking over my shoulder even
higher understanding you're chatting I
the speaker against her formal role is
over but the idea that she's not going
to play a role in the rooms behind the
scenes with the managers who are going
to be making their argument here in the
coming days and weeks is simply she's
gonna be in all those meetings she's
going to be helping set up direction
where they are are directing their
thinking their resources how they decide
to lay out this case and she's going to
be working very closely with Adam Schiff
on this and of course the big question
that's looming over all of this how he's
going to play out in the Senate with
witnesses and new evidence it's unlikely
that we're going to get answers to those
questions for some days if not weeks
morning everyone how are you
that said over and over again every day
that we're involved in this
impeachment is a sad day for America and
yesterday was one when we were given no
choice but to send to the Senate two
articles of impeachment against Donald
Trump the President of the United States
for his president necessitated this by
his abuse of power and his obstruction
of Congress and his actions which
undermined our national security
violated his oath of office to protect
and defend the Constitution
i jeopardized the integrity of our
elections every day new incriminating
evidence forward you're well aware of
the hearings last night I think that
only speaks very clearly to the need for
the Senate undermine - a and this is
that the day the Government Accounting
Office confirmed that the president's
actions at the center of our impeachment
articles withholding congressionally
approved military aid from Ukraine was
illegal and these are their words these
are the words of the GAO faithful
execution of the law does not permit the
President to substitute his own policy
priorities for those that Congress has
enacted into law the Office of
Management budget withheld funds for a
policy reason which is not permitted
under the empowerment Control Act the
was holding was not a programmatic to
therefore we conclude that OMB violated
the empowerment Act the pret V OMB the
White House the administration broke I'm
saying this broke the law they say we
concludes that they violated the
empowerment Control Act this reinforces
again need for documents and
eyewitnesses in the Senate when I was in
grade school there was a sign on the
wall and one of the Carter's it said
what a tangled web we weave when we
first practice to deceive you see this
more and more and more and all of this
this tangled web to deceive that the
administration is engaged in also on
Appropriations matters I'm very sad
about what has happened in Puerto Rico
we pray for the families who have lost
loved ones and and injury to others the
appropriation it's unacceptable that the
administration illegally withheld for
over a year the federal assistance that
Congress appropriated and that Puerto
Rico needs but concerned that the
administration may be looking for
excuses to create unnecessary obstacles
to the timely flow of assistance based
on reports of new restrictions on the
aid we hope that that can be interpreted
more loosely but we're concerned we hope
that the president will soon sign a
major major disaster declaration for
earthquake Republic he has signed an a
emergency when we need the major
disaster our fellow port Americans and
Puerto Rico American citizens all need
assistance now that's why today the
house will be let her bring wood more
loose again we pray for the families of
the two Americans who died in the
disaster related tragedies but we're
concerned about those who are affected
physically and also traumatically by the
earthquake and by the uncertainty that
we are not there for them
as you know in the election Democrats
ran on a platform of for the people for
the people we were lower the cost of
health care by lowering the cost of
prescription drugs we would increase
lower health care costs bigger paychecks
by building the infrastructure of
America and a green resilient way and
that we would have cleaner government we
passed HR 1 to do that in terms of lower
health care costs right before Christmas
we passed HR 3 to lower the cost of
prescription drugs it's been widely and
popularly received throughout the
country we're very proud of it it's just
again another bill sitting on the desk
of the Grim Reaper on the Senate side
400 bills have we passed 275 of them
bipartisan sitting on the leaders desk
one of them is about is about gun
violence and that passes passing that
bill and having it signed into law would
save lives but that's just one of many
but in terms of prescription drug we
should they have a bill we have a bill
let's pass them and go to conference but
they're not only not taking a barbell
now you're taking up their bill
increasing paychecks that when we come
back that first week we will be rolling
out our infrastructure legislation the
work of more than one committee but led
by the infrastructure and transportation
committee Peter DeFazio it is it's
pretty exciting it's something we talked
about during the campaign it's something
the president talked about as a priority
during the campaign we thought we would
be able to move in a positive way on
this so far they have not come on board
however we decided now we'll just have
to go forward and we do believe that now
with the passage of the met the US
Mexico Canada agreement that they might
be interested in cooperating in other
ways and on that score pleased that the
Senate is going to be taking up the bill
this morning I think it will be passed
and then we'll sign it and send it over
the legislators will sign it and send it
over to the president
what is amazing to me is that the
us/mexico can green and I'm gonna pass
them out to the US Mexico Canada
agreement okay that's good news for all
of us because we view that as a job spin
I want to commend Ritchie Neal and our
members are eight members who were part
of our task force to make sure we
changed the bill that they sent us we
could never have supported the treaty
that they had sent us but what we sent
back to them in terms of again
enforcement enforcement enforcement but
enforcement labor rights environmental
protections and eliminating their give
away to pharma that was in the bill
among other other improvements that we
made on the bill so we're police we had
a big strong vote in the house and glad
that because we didn't send over and but
it gave them enough time to bring it up
this morning because these the Chief
Justice won't be able to be there until
this afternoon and when we talk about
health care I said I mentioned yesterday
we had a beautiful ceremony they don't
know if any of you thought give me a
gold medal - Stephen Gleason former NFL
new on the state's flight strong and and
he has a he's been diagnosed with ALS in
a very now late stages of it
but in the course of meeting his
challenge he helped do so many things
for other people with ALS or
neuromuscular diagnosis it was a
beautiful thing
but it points out that all of us are one
diagnosis our families are one diagnosis
one phone call one accident away from
needing really affordable quality health
care we all need it every day but this
catastrophic so very important and that
is again we're particularly proud of the
progress that we've made now what we're
up against is the president on every
front in the Congress and in the courts
is trying to undo the Affordable Care
Act
the Patient Protection and Affordable
Care Act and right now he goes out and
says he's the protector I mean where's
it again what a web we read when we
practice to deceive
how can he possibly go out there and
saying he's protecting the pre-existing
condition benefit and things like that
when he is in court trying to overturn
it instead of the just Alan says she's
attacked or I mean land in the courts so
that's her fight and we have asked for
expedited decision from the court so
that the public will know what we are up
against they if said take it slow take
it slow take it slow so this is a very
very important issue to the health of
the American people but also the
financial health of the American of the
American people so we were very proud
when we passed the Elijah Cummings hr3
lower drug cost now that is something so
remarkable so transformative in terms of
meeting the needs America's working
families but also taking the money saved
from Big Pharma's ripoff and greed and
using it to transform Medicare in a way
that it hasn't been transformed since
its inception and that is to take about
a half a trillion dollars at a farmer
profits and use it for dental hearing
and official benefits so we're very
excited about that and again on this
pre-existing condition is about 130
million families are affected by
pre-existing conditions and president
and is in court trying to overturn that
so no longer will that benefit be
available to people are no longer will
the benefit of of no lifetime limits or
annual limits on it the list goes on and
on about that when we come back we'll
also be addressing surprise billing
issue but that's one of the but come
back we'll have the first week we'll
have rollout infrastructure probably on
the floor and this
all up to the Democratic leader but he
has told me it had told our caucus that
respect in the first week we would be
bringing up the rock on a bill which
says no funds for Warren in Iran unless
Congress would approve that and also
Barbara Lee's legislation which repeals
the antique authorization of the use of
military force that AUMF that has been
used for justification that is beyond
its scope so there we are the again
we're very pleased with since we
returned from Christmas we passed the
PFS that is to clean up toxic chemicals
these are forever chemicals you can
practically not get away with them get
get rid of them but it impacts millions
of families and many is the it they
serve our country these people and their
families are negatively affected and
I've met with some of the families and
it's such a tragedy it's such a tragedy
then we passed a War Powers Resolution
to limit the president's military
actions in Iran and soon the Senate will
be taking up Senator Kane's version of
that then it would pass the CR a to
reverse an administration rule denying
debt relief to students defrauded by
predatory institutions it's just a
stunning thing these kids they incur
debt the institutions have disappeared
their degrees are not worth what they
have had borrowed money to obtain and
this administration wants to protect not
the students but the predatory lenders
so with that we happy to take any
questions you may have
now you were at last question yesterday
no is it they are afraid of the truth
the American people have seen the
allegations and their allegations we
need to see more evidence that was would
be contained in the documentation so
there this is just another avoiding of
the facts and the truth on their part
they don't want to see documents they
don't want to hear from eyewitnesses
they don't want to they want to ignore
anything new that comes up we saw a
strong case and infallible undeniable
case for the impeachment of the
president so no future president would
ever think that she or he could get away
with what President Trump has been
getting away with in his view any
further evidence should not be avoided
and now it's in the ball was in the
court of the Senate a public opinion
will have a lot to do with this since we
passed ours and then sent it over public
opinion has grown enormous Lee we're
seeing witnesses eyewitnesses and
documentation and they'll just have to
contend with the public on that yes I
think that they're different the
facebook business model is strictly to
make money they don't care about the
impact on children they don't care about
truths they don't care about where this
is all coming from and they have said
even if they know it's not true they
will print it I think that they had been
very abusive the the great opportunity
that technology has given them Mike my
thought about them is
they don't want they all they wonder
their tax cuts and no antitrust action
against them and they schmooze this
administration in that regard because so
far that's what they have received but I
think that their what they have said
very blatantly very clearly that they
intend to be accomplices for misleading
the American people with money from God
knows where they didn't even check on
the money from Russia in the last
election then everyone thought they
should so they have been very
irresponsible and again as you say these
are people that we've known and worked
with over time actually Facebook stay on
the peninsula but they do have an office
in my district and I think their
behavior is shameful well they were
released now because that's when they
were changed and and then his going
further into public interviews
on that is very compelling but again why
would they not want to find out under
other circumstances if somebody like
Parnas came forward and there was
evidence there was reason to believe
that there was some of that was factual
there would be a special prosecutor
appointed does anybody think that the
rogue Attorney General is going to
support a appoint a special prosecutor
no because he's implicated in all of
this this is an example of all of the
president's henchmen and I hope that the
Senators do not become part of the
president's henchmen
well incredible it relates to the
documents and the rest it certainly
raises questions but now I've appointed
two managers who haunted me tracked me
who are they when do they come in where
they're here and they have a
responsibility and I'm very confident in
how they will proceed and the again
there seems to be documentation that
would validate what Parnas is saying but
that all has to be subjected to scrutiny
he'd be a credible witness if what he's
testifying to relates to the issue at
hand the president's behavior but again
there's a process for for how you go
forward with witnesses and that's not
done in the basement of the
Congressional visitors center but in you
know among those who are making those
decisions about how to go forward and
I'm so proud of our managers our members
have been so positive and about it and
you know this is not without risk
they're going to give off great deal of
their intellect as an intellectual
resource as a pick as Patriots giving a
great deal of time of course but also
their courageous let me just say that
way they're courageous and excuse me I
told you I wasn't entering you had a
question yesterday when I said that the
Attorney General was implicated as I
said this testimony implicated the rogue
attorney general who has been of the
puppet of what make I don't know who's
the puppet Trumpler or the Attorney
General but this is not he says this is
my attorney general this is my
Department of Justice
really so in any case it's not a
question of saying what proof it
says what allegations have been made and
that has to be subjected to scrutiny as
to how we go forward but it should not
be ignored in the context of other
events that have happened that would
substantiate some so in any case it's
not right up to the president I mean the
president has some options he can come
that day and we are prepared to welcome
him that day he could send a printed
copy which was for a long time the
tradition the president would send a
copy of his State of the Union address
or he could ask us to postpone it if in
fact he wants to have it after all of
this is resolved but the timing of the
investigation of the the trial of the
president for obstructing Congress and
abuse of power should not be hastened
because of a speech he wants to make to
the Congress of the United States thank
you all very much
[Music]
I know this is the hardest part you're
almost there we love you started on
Thursday at 10:00 Thursday at 10:30
still going strong and it's Saturday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I understand like no one from us yet
they these kind of conditions before we
are used to pollution like we play in
China we play in more polluted countries
but I mean this is smoky something
different than for sure we are not used
to it and I think I mean citizens and
everyone was advised to stay inside and
I'm we didn't expect that we will be
playing yesterday so I was a bit
shocking I found it a good reason to
paint in Hong Kong to give gift to the
Hong Kong people to encourage them in
their struggle which reminds me even to
the west and east struggle we had in
Germany
[Music]
the woman is Hong Kong the woman is
Arthi Hong Kong people this captures
that the drama of the struggle
so is she rising or is she thinking the
crown represents
to cover herself but the struggle as
he's been saying is about the struggles
taking place in many parts of the world
[Music]
art is like highest form of
communication so people understand art
by their feelings by their emotions and
so I reckon art is more easily to
understand than politics
I wanted to set a mark like two
different systems should get together
I reckon crowns on the people because
everybody should feel like a queen or
king and and now we have one Germany and
everybody lives in Sweden and it was a
peaceful revolution as an artist I have
a responsibility also for freedom and
also to fight for it and to show it to
other people here to encourage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know this is the hardest part you're
almost there we love you start it on
Thursday at 10:00 Thursday at 10:30
still going strong and it's Saturday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I understand like no one from us yet
they these kind of conditions before we
are used to pollution like we play in
China we play in more polluted countries
but I mean this is smoky something
different than for sure we are not used
to it and I think I mean citizens and
everyone was advised to stay inside and
I'm we didn't expected we will be
playing yesterday was a bit shocking I
found it a good reason to paint in Hong
Kong to give gift to the Hong Kong
people to encourage them in their
struggle which reminds me even to the
West and East struggle we had in Germany
[Music]
the woman is Hong Kong what's up with
that
where's the love I just don't see it I
don't see this at all right today we had
a conference and Republicans in the
house across the country you see some
very good news from our conference chair
this morning with Liz Cheney announcing
that she will remain on our leadership
team and remain in the house she's a
fighter and she is a powerful voice for
conservatives and is the type of person
we need to help us lead the charge to
win back the majority Liz i speak on
behalf of our members when i say thank
you for your commitment to the
republican party into the vision that
will truly help propel americans across
the country for a better future what you
need to read into it is there a real
chance that we're gonna win the majority
the idea that our conference share an
opportunity to go to the Senate she
chose to stay here to help us win the
majority I thank her for that now let me
shift to what we saw yesterday in this
chamber the taxpayer-funded campaign
stunts for the Democrats
they took Americans hard-earned dollars
and funneled them into years of
worthless or baseless investigation
meant to discredit this president and
after three years with zero facts to
back up their accusations Democrats
rammed impeachment down the throats of
the American people if this was real if
this was really as serious as they
claimed this would be yesterday was no
cause for celebration
but in that case Democrats did what you
would expect in a campaign event posed
for pictures smiled handed out gifts to
one another and speaker Pelosi even
fist-pumped on the House floor during
what should have been a serious debate
I'm sure most of you got a pin as well
their behavior is disgusting an
appalling every person in this country
should be enraged at the fraud the waste
and abuse they have seen from Democrats
in this majority millions of dollars
spent countless hours lost when their
unrelenting hatred towards this
president it is not enough - speaker
Pelosi and her colleagues have been
determined to embarrass the president in
our own country but there is a worse
trend that has taken on whenever the
president is helping to strengthen our
country on the international stage
Democrats are trying to bring him down
on Capitol Hill let me point that out to
you September 24th the president was at
the United Nations General Assembly two
colleagues to announce impeachment
December 4th the president was at the
NATO leaders meeting Democrats hold a
hearing with law professors and
yesterday as the president was on
Pennsylvania Avenue signing phase one of
a trade deal with China
speaker Pelosi after needless waiting
for a month decides that it is a day
she'll send articles of impeachment to
the Senate they're sabotage has failed
their juvenile behavior has only
succeeded in showing the American people
the sharp contrast between this failed
majority what real leadership looks like
it was a progress on the China trade
deal yesterday and today the Senate is
expected to pass the United States
Mexico Canada agreement promises made
promises kept most people did not think
this president could accomplish this he
did something others could not
he first promised the American public he
would do it and he carried it out he
carried it out at the same time that
this majority spent their entire time
trying to investigate him he never let
that get him down I'll guarantee you
this when we are back in the majority we
will take our responsibilities seriously
and we will stay committed to helping
you the American people open for
questions yes ma'am
100% yes OMB response was that they
disagreed with the GAO his opinion OMB
uses it apportion authority to ensure
taxpayer dollars are properly spent
these are taxpayer dollars going to
another country that people believe
there was corruption with the new
administration I think it was the
rightful thing to do yes no no this man
lacks all credibility this is the same
pattern I've seen before with Cohen with
Abbiati the media tries to build
something into it just didn't show that
he went on in the net he was not so he
doesn't have any credibility not at all
you have the transcript of the phone
call that's all you need you have the
phone call that's what they're based
there impeachment on even though their
managers had decided on impeachment you
have Hakeem who voted for it two years
almost to this date a year before the
phone call even took place you have Adam
Schiff who met with the whistleblower
bolide said he had proof beyond
circumstantial we found that was not to
be true
so no you don't need anything more they
made their case for impeachment the
Senate role now is to judge it and
that's what those through
well the trial could be completed by
then how weak the true how a week the
cases itself but I'd leave that up to
the president I think it would be
appropriate for him to be able to speak
to the American public when they can all
watch and listen every time he's given
the State of the Union walking away the
country feels stronger country has a
better understanding of where they're
going more hope more opportunity I want
to make sure he's given that opportunity
unfortunately the way that the speaker
has held her papers when it was such an
urgency when she got nothing in the
process of holding it but really harming
any senator that's running for president
they will be sitting in their chair for
six days with no phones can't campaign
I'm not sure Nancy Pelosi was waiting on
all those pins to arrive to ordering
them I'm not sure why she held the
papers because she she achieved nothing
by it
any other question yes sir this exact
day all right a week ago yes please
please I I don't know how much money he
gave me when it came out in the press if
you'll look I've been pretty successful
I have raised more money then as the
leader of the Republican Party is as the
speaker of the Republican Party before
me people come to events and they take
photos with me this seems to be the case
I saw a photo that he had on there that
he actually walked up to me at the
inaugural could you see he put his hat
around me and snapped a picture like
hundreds of thousands of other people
and did as well that seems to be of
interest to you when I found out that
this individual had given money to
take back our I don't know this take
protect the house it was given away to
charity I don't know what more you need
by that I know because you come back
every week with the same question I'm
not sure I check ok let's be let's be
let's be honest and fair ok you just
know you just said a week ago you asked
me the question I answered now I
answered the same question again we can
do this each and every week but the
facts don't change last week when you
asked me the question the money he
provided was said was sent to do I get
answers do I get answer as well because
you did to you ok once you let me answer
last week when you asked me the question
it was the same facts it was this week
that we gave the money away it already
shows that it does ok let me release
everything I know and everything of fine
ok you're done with your question yes
all right let me be very clear to you
the exact same answer you've had every
other week that you've ever asked me I
do not know the man he came to a
fundraiser and he provided me money I
learned from the media that he provided
money to a fund a learning of that
information we gave that to charity I
think that will answer the same question
and you come back next week
[Music]
you
[Music]